Tucker Carlson was fired from Fox two
weeks ago now and there's been a lot of
speculation about what Tucker will do
now that he's been fired we now have an
answer starting soon we'll be bringing a
new version of the show we've been doing
for the last six and a half years to
Twitter free speech is the main right
that you have without it you have no
others that's huge and I have to say
I'm feeling pretty good about our
decision to bring our show to Twitter a
couple weeks ago if you want to again
drive the conversation
um and the News cycle Twitter does that
a lot more than YouTube does which is
why on YouTube you know you can have
YouTube stars who have tens of millions
of subscribers but outside of YouTube no
one's even heard of them if you become
prominent on Twitter then you're going
to be in the kind of national
conversation so it makes sense
strategically and now that it's that
that Twitter is run by the richest guy
in the world who also happens to be an
advocate of free speech it makes sense
to uh to make this move